INSTRUCTOR: Hi,
Data 2100 students.
We're going to jump into our
in-class assignment called
Python Basics today.
Now, if you have not already
watched the prior videos
regarding our
introduction to Python,
please make sure that you have.
In this in-class assignment, I
want you to try it on your own,
and then we're going to
come together and work
on it together.
So if you've yet
to try to attempt
to complete this on your
own, please pause the video,
go and complete it,
and then come back.
All right, so if you click
on the link in the assignment
itself, on that
Python Basics link,
it will take you to this Jupyter
Notebook file hosted here
in Google Colab.
So Google Colab is our
Python integrated development
environment that we
have talked about.
This is where we're going
to code, debug, deploy
our Python code.
You will notice that once
you click on that link,
if you're already signed
in to your Gmail account,
then you can just
press Copy to Drive.
I have not yet signed in.
So I'm going to go ahead
and do that with you.
So we'll see, make sure
that that works just fine.
OK, perfect.
So then we'll press Continue.
So then once I'm signed in, I'm
going to click on Copy to Drive.
This is going to make a copy
of this in-class assignment
in your own Google Drive folder.
And it will autoassign it to
a folder called Google Colabs.
So now instead of saying,
Copy of ICA:Python Basics,
I'm going to say
Siggard_ICA:Python Basics.
So I've asked you,
again, to rename all
of your Jupyter Notebook files.
You're going to say,
"Siggard" or your last name.
So do your last
name_ICA:Python Basics, OK?
All right, so now,
in this assignment,
we're going to do
some basic Python.
You are going to submit
two files for all
of our Python assignments.
You're going to submit a
PDF version of the file
as well as a Jupyter
Notebook file.
Basically, Jupyter
Notebooks allow us
to-- so if you see here,
this is all textual data
or textual instructions.
Then I give you Program
1's instructions.
And then I give
you a code block.
This is where we will
write our Python code
to complete Program number 1.
So this will hopefully
work out very well
for our Python
assignments this semester.
All right, so I want you
to create four programs.
And we're going to go
ahead and do this together.
So we are going to create
a program by following the
below instructions.
"Assign the variable
x a value of 20.22.
Do not create any
other variables."
All right, so let's
go ahead and do that.
So I'm going to delete out
that "write that code."
# And I'm going to say,
all right, #declaring x.
I'm going to make good
use of comments here.
And I'll say, all
right, x = 20.22.
Then I will use the variable
to print out x = to 20.22.
And then the square
root of x is blank.
All right, so let's
go ahead and do this.
So I'm going to say, print.
We're going to use the f strings
that we've been learning about.
And I want to print
"X is equal to."
And I want to use
that variable x.
So I'm going to use my
brackets, my square brackets.
You'll have to press Shift.
And then the square brackets
are generally the default.
But we actually want
the curly brackets.
So we're going to
say, "X is equal to."
And then I want to place
the variable x there,
which means that when
this code is run,
it will place the value
from the variable x
exactly where we have this here.
Then I'll say, The
square root of x is.
And then I want to
do some arithmetic.
So I want to say, you know what?
Let's have x.
And I want to "square
root of x is."
And I'll do some arithmetic.
And I'm going to say, x** 0.5.
What this means is take the
value from the variable x,
raise it to the 1/2
power, if you will,
which is the same thing as
taking the square root of x.
So let's just run this
and see how this works.
It's going to take
a second here.
It's initializing.
Perfect.
So now we'll say, X
is equal to 20.22.
The square root of x is blank.
So I can use variables here.
And I can also manipulate
those variables a little bit
inside of those curly brackets.
OK, perfect.
Now, the next thing that I
want to do is I want to say,
20.22 + 20.22 is equal to blank.
And, I again, just want
to use the x variable
to help me do this.
So I'll go ahead and
say, print, again,
using my f strings that are
very concise and readable.
And I want to grab the
value from the variable x
to place here.
So I'll say, x + x is equal to.
And then I want to place the
value that x is equal to.
So x + x is equal to.
So then I'll say, all right,
let's do some arithmetic.
So I'll say, return
the value of x + x
right here in these
curly brackets.
So, again, x is my variable.
I am using these variables
in my print statements
to make sure that I'm only
referencing that one variable.
Then it makes it a lot
easier as we're just
referencing those variables here
and using these curly brackets.
So again, these curly
brackets are saying,
take the value
from that variable
and place it here
where I'm basically
saving a place for it
using these curly brackets
and f strings.
All right, so now I'll
go ahead and press Play.
And I have 20.22 +
20.22 is equal to 40.44,
which is perfect.
So question number
1 then is done.
And, again, I know my
program is done running when
the Play icon shows back up.
And there's that
green check mark.
I know that that's done.
I can just press Play here,
or I can say Shift-Enter.
Either way, it will
run this code block.
You'll notice that
up above, we say
that you write the code for
each of the programs below.
After completing the coding,
run each of your programs
by clicking the Play button on
the left side of each code box.
Before submitting, make sure
the output of each program
is viewable beneath
the code box,
basically, that you've ran this.
So you'll see here
that this program
output is viewable to us.
So we're good to go there.
And then I'll show
you how to submit.
So now on question
number 2, we're
going to write a program
that asks the user
to input their last name.
So we learned about
variables this week.
We learned about input.
So let's go ahead and do that.
We also learned about,
of course, arithmetic.
# So I'm going to say,
#ask for user's name.
All right, so let's
go ahead and do this.
I'm going to say,
user name, also,
uname is equal to input
"What is your name?"
So I'm going to ask my user.
Now, as a reminder, these angle
brackets are not necessary.
But this command here is
going to grab whatever
my user's input as the input and
assign it to the variable uname.
So the value of
the variable uname
is going to be equal to whatever
my user inputs to this question.
So now I'll run this, and
I'll say, what is your name?
And let's just say, Reagan.
Now, I enter that.
Nothing else happens because
I didn't tell my program
to output anything.
So it's just saying,
all right, we
know that uname is
now equal to Reagan,
but that's all that
we really know.
So once I've asked the
user to input their name,
then I want to-- oh, sorry,
to the variable username.
I did not follow my
own instructions.
Whoa, whoa.
Sorry.
All right, there
we go, username.
[LAUGHS] OK, there we go.
Then print out "Hi, [username].
How are you?"
using f strings on
two different lines.
Only use one print statement.
That should say,
using an f string.
I'll just fix that really quick.
Your version will be fixed.
So don't worry about that.
But as I'm recording,
this I just noticed that.
All right, so let's
go ahead and do that.
I will say, all right,
print Hi, [username].
So we'll say, f shtring "Hi."
And then I want to place the
value from the variable username
in here.
So I'll use my brackets.
I'll say, username.
Sweet.
Hi, username.
Awesome.
"How are you?"
OK, but it says,
using an f string
and on two different lines.
Let's just run this.
We run our programs often.
So I'll say, "Reagan,"
and it says, "Hi, Reagan.
How are you?"
How cool.
We are inputting some
data into our program,
and it is outputting to us
that same data and using it.
But it says here, using an f
string, which we did, right?
Our formatting strings here,
and on two different lines.
So here, I want to create
using my escape characters
that we've talked about.
I'm going to use a backslash n.
On my keyboard, that backslash
is up above the Enter.
But you're going to have to
find it on your own keyboard.
All right, so now I run this.
And we'll say, "Reagan" again.
It says, "Hi, Reagan.
How are you?"
Notice this backslash n says,
hey, enter a new line, "Hi,
Reagan," period, new
line, "How are you?"
That's what this
backslash n does.
These are called
escape characters.
And we can do a new line.
We can do a tab, what have you.
But this is one way that
we can format our program.
So those are escape characters.
They're really
helpful in formatting
our output of our program.
All right, now I want to create
a program by following, again,
the instructions.
And I want to ask the user to
input their favorite number.
All right, so let's see here.
You're going to see that these
programs are going to become
a little bit more advanced.
But we're just starting out with
what we've learned thus far.
So some of these programs
are kind of funny.
But I promise that
we'll be increasing
the difficulty and the business
questions associated with them.
But this is just
great to practice.
# All right, so #ask the user
for their favorite number.
That's my first thing
that I want to do.
So I'm going to say,
all right, favenumber.
So I'm declaring the
variable favenumber.
I'm assigning the
value of that variable
to be whatever is returned
to me by my user's input.
Again, angle bracket
is not necessary.
It just helps with
formatting OK,
so let's just make
sure this runs.
What is your favorite number?
I say, 6.
I hit Enter.
All right, that ran just fine.
Then what I'm supposed to do is
assign the value of the input
to the variable favenumber,
which we just did.
"If the number is over 10, tell
the user that their number is
incredibly high and to please
tone it down for next time."
All right, so once
we have declared
the variable
favenumber, whatever
the input is going to be
assigned to that variable fave
number as its value.
# Now, I want to say, #if the
number is over 10, do this.
So we're going to use
conditional statements,
using if statements
that we've talked about.
So I'll use a
conditional statement.
And I'll say, if the favenumber
is greater than 10, then
what do I want to do?
Well, when I hit
Enter, you'll notice
that it'll automatically
indent beneath
that conditional statement.
Everything indented and beneath
this conditional statement,
if this is true,
if that is true,
then I will do everything
indented in beneath it.
So if that's true, then I
want to print to them "Yikes!
That is an incredibly
high number.
Please tone it down
for next time."
All right, OK, so
let's just go ahead
and run what we have thus far.
So I can say Shift-Enter,
and it will run.
What is your favorite number?
We can see my
program is running.
It's waiting for
us to enter input.
So you wait for your program
to run-- or it's running.
Now, I'm going to say,
7 is my favorite number.
Then I hit Enter.
Rut-row.
It's like, OK, TypeError--
greater than not supported
between instances
of 'str' and 'int'.
OK, let's figure this out.
So if you remember back
in our lecture videos,
I told you that input is
always interpreted as a string.
String, think textual
data, like a name, right?
That's going to be
interpreted as a string.
10 is an integer.
So 10 is an integer.
But favenumber, you can
see here is a string,
because the value from
the input is assigned
to be the favenumber's value.
And input is always
interpreted as a string.
So I cannot compare a string and
an integer, because it's like,
well, these are apples
and oranges, right?
So instead, I need to make
sure I convert favenumber
to actually be an integer
before this if statement runs.
So I'll say, favenumber = to
input "What Is your favorite
number?"
And before I can do that, I'm
going to say, you know what?
I'm going to ask, what
is your favorite number?
Then after that, I'm
going to use this integer.
It's going to convert, using
this integer function, whatever
they entered as their
input to be an integer.
So now 16 is their
favorite number.
We're going to assume that they
actually put an integer here.
Then I'm going to convert
that entry into an integer
and assign it to favenumber.
So input runs here first,
this inner parenthesis,
then the integer value.
The integer function works next.
So now when I run this, What
is your favorite number?
I'm going to say, 7.
Hit Enter.
My program is done, and
nothing returns to me, right?
Because this
condition is not true.
My favorite number is
not greater than 10,
so nothing output to me.
So let's do it again.
And let's say,
actually, it's 12.
Now, I'll hit Enter again,
and it says, "Yikes!
That is an incredibly
high number.
Please tone it down
for next time."
So this conditional
statement is true.
So then this print runs, right?
All right, OK, perfect.
Now, what I want to do--
"Otherwise, tell the user that
you appreciate them entering
their favorite number and return
their favorite number to them."
OK, so let's come down here.
I'm going to say,
else favenumber--
oh, sorry. else-- and
else does not have--
I was thinking I
was doing an elif.
Else does not have any
conditional expression
after that.
So it's just basically
saying, else,
meaning if the number
is 10 or less, right?
If this is not true,
then run my else block
and we'll print
out to them print.
And we're going to use
some variables here.
So we'll say, print "Thank
you for sharing your favorite
number."
And I'm going to place
their favorite number
in here using that favenumber
variable that they entered.
And I'll say, "It
is a great choice."
All right, so we'll go
ahead and press Play.
What is your favorite number?
Let's say, 12.
I'll hit Enter.
"Yikes!
That is an incredibly
high number.
Please tone it down
for next time."
I'm going to run it again.
You'll notice my program
is still running.
It's waiting for me
to enter my input.
So now I'll say,
7, and I hit Enter.
It says, "Thank you for sharing
your favorite number, 7.
It is a great choice."
All right, perfect.
So I don't know why I chose
that-- the number was over 10.
I have no idea.
But this demonstrates
the if and the else.
All right, awesome.
And of course,
input and how is it
always interpreted as a string.
So we must convert it
to be an integer if we
want to use it like an integer.
All right, finally,
here, we're going
to create a program by following
the below instructions.
"Create a variable
called mypassword."
So down here, I'm going
to say, all right,
#create variable mypassword.
I'm going to say,
mypassword is equal to.
And I want to "assign a
five-letter fake password
to this variable."
So I'm going to say
my password = 'happy.'
And we'll notice here we
can use these single quotes
or double quotes.
I tend to focus more
on the double quotes.
That's just my
personal preference.
All right, so then I'm going
to say, userguess is equal to--
it says up here,
"to this variable.
Ask user to guess your
five-letter password.
If they guess your password
correctly, output 'Nice job!
You guessed my password'.
Insert password."
So you can say, userguess =
input "Guess my five-character
password."
So we're going to
ask the user to guess
my five-character password.
So my user is going
to guess that.
It's not going to matter.
If it's interpreted as a
string, that's great actually,
because mypassword itself,
if it is a string, if they
guess your password
correctly, output "Nice job!
You guess my password."
So I'm going to
compare, did they
guess my password correctly?
So I'm going to use
an if statement.
And I'm going to
say, you know what?
And I oftentimes
will put, especially
as we get more complex,
my conditional statements
within parentheses.
I'll say, if my
userguess == mypassword,
we must use these double equal
signs when doing a conditional
statement or a comparison here.
If not, that's going to think
I'm trying to assign userguess
to mypassword.
It just doesn't work quite well.
So we need to use those
double equal sign.
# And I'll say, you know what? #if
the user guesses my password,
do this.
So then I'm going
to print "Nice job!
You guessed my password."
And I'm going to return
to them my password, which
is the value from the
variable [? mypassword ?].
You notice here
that I forgot to put
the f in front of the
double quotes to tell it.
I'm using a formatting string.
So make sure that you do that.
All right, so I'm
going to tell them
that you guessed my
password, which is awesome.
Now, let's go
ahead and run this.
It's going to wait for me to
guess my five-letter password.
Let's say, apple.
I hit Enter.
Nothing runs because
this is not true.
And so nothing runs.
Now, let's play this again.
Guess my five-letter password.
If I say, happy, then "Nice job!
You guessed, oh, my
password, happy."
So I'm going to
delete that L there.
All right, and we're good to go.
Now, the next part
that I want to do
is if they didn't guess
your password correctly, see
if the password was the
correct number of letters.
If they did enter a
five-letter password,
then tell them they did not
correctly guess your password.
But they did guess the
right number of letters.
OK, so let's come over here,
and we're going to say,
you know what?
Elif, so this is just another
conditional statement.
If I'm dealing here, I'm
in the same if block,
still working with my
userguess and password.
So if this one is not true, then
try and see if my elif is true.
And I'll say, elif
is the length.
Len is my length function.
And it goes in and identifies
how many characters is
my userguess variable's value.
So if the length of userguess is
== to the length of mypassword,
so is it the correct length?
Is it five letters?
I'm going to say, print.
So I could say elif
length == to 5,
or I can say length
of my password.
I might actually say because
I'm being specific up here
that they did--
I'm just going to
say equal to 5.
So I could do either way
here because my password
is of five characters.
I could say the length
of userguess == to length
of my password or
just equal to 5.
But I want to be
specific to 5 here.
Either way could work.
So I'm going to tell them
that if this is true, then--
# let's see-- #they don't
guess my password,
but they do guess a
five-letter password.
So I'll say if that length
of userguess is == to 5,
I'll print "You incorrectly
guessed my password,
but you did guess a
five-letter password."
Perfect.
Then the next thing that I'm
going to do is let's run this.
So I'm going to say, apple.
That's five characters.
And it says, "You incorrectly
guessed my password,"
which is true, "but you did
guess a five-letter password."
So what it does is it goes
through this if statement first.
If that userguess is ==
to mypassword, run this.
This was not true
for this instance.
So then the elif ran.
Is this true?
This was true because
apple is five characters.
So it ran "You incorrectly
guessed my password,
but you did guess a
five-letter password."
So now let's run it again.
Oh, actually, I'm not
going to run it again.
I'm going to stop it
here really quick.
So I keyboard interrupted it.
[LAUGHS]
Last thing I want to
do, if they did not
input a five-character password
nor guess your password,
tell them of their failure.
So we're going to go
ahead and say else,
if neither of these
conditions are true,
then they know that they didn't
guess my password correctly,
and that they didn't guess
a five-character password.
So I'll say print "You did not
correctly guess my password,
nor did you enter a
five-letter password."
So now when I run
this, let's just enter
a random number of characters.
It says, "You did not
correctly guess my password,
nor did you enter a
five-letter password."
I'll run it again, check
everything on more time.
I'll say, happy.
This is the correct password.
I hit Enter.
It says, "Nice job!
You guessed my password, happy."
If I run this one
more time and I say,
guess my five-letter
password and I say, apple,
I hit Enter again, "You
incorrectly guessed my password,
but you did guess a
five-letter password."
So my elif ran that time.
All right, so here, you have
your in-class assignment
done for Python Basics.
Please review workbook files
as you need to as well.
I'm going to submit two
different files to Canvas.
So go File.
You're going to first submit a--
so go File and
then down to Print.
You can't see it on my end,
but I'm going to say, Print.
And you'll say, Microsoft
Print to PDF or Save as PDF.
And then you'll say, Print.
And you have to do
the Print to PDF.
It won't let you Save As.
Maybe I'm going to save
it to my Downloads folder.
And I'll say,
Siggard_ICAPythonBasics.
So oh, it might not
let that happen.
All right, PythonBasics.
Now, I'll press Save.
Then I also want you to just
download the Jupyter Notebook
file.
And it's downloaded
that as well.
So I want you to submit
both this and the PDF
that you just created.
I'll show you what
the PDF looks like.
The PDF is actually really
helpful for grading,
because on our end, once we have
ensured that all of that output
has ran, we ran all
of our programs,
we can go through and see,
oh, there's your output.
There's your output
for number 2.
for number 3.
And there's your
output for number 4.
So please make sure you
follow the instructions.
You're going to submit the PDF
and the Jupyter Notebook file.
Thanks for being
an awesome class.
This has been a fun semester.
Take care.